something a little bit different today
usually my uh we read comments in this
segment from and messages comments and
messages from people attacking me for
things that I said that's the point of
the of the segment but this time we have
comments and messages from people
attacking me for things I didn't say and
not that they're accusing me of saying
things I didn't say but rather they are
mad at me for not saying certain things
and we talked earlier in the show about
the recent Trump interviews uh where he
said stuff that I didn't like and I
explained why I didn't like it I
explained that today just a few minutes
ago because I'm back at work because
it's Monday and I did not however say
anything about these subjects on Twitter
over the weekend
until Sunday night uh you know when I
start doing a show property a little
work on Sunday
um but for most of the weekend I didn't
say anything at all about any subject
I was silent because I'm a married man
with six kids and I don't spend my
weekends on Twitter at least I try not
to actually just to give you just to
give you the full timeline here you know
I talked about Trump's I talked about
Trump's Megyn Kelly interview I think
that was on Thursday
and we talked about the fauci stuff and
I was very critical of how he handled
the fauci stuff the question about why
did you give them a commendation all
that I didn't mention the trans stuff
because I didn't I didn't I hadn't seen
that clip I didn't know about it I
didn't watch the full interview I saw
the clips
um I only saw the fauji clip I finally
saw the trans clip on Friday afternoon
probably but at that point I was heading
to dinner with my wife it's it's you
know this is the end of the work week
for me going out for a date night I
decided I'll wait till Monday we could
talk about it in Greater depth this is
the kind of thing I want to flesh out I
want to talk about
uh then over the weekend as we did on
just a few minutes ago
then over the weekend the the Trump Meet
the Press interview came out it came out
on Sunday morning
and I didn't see that at all because at
first because it's Sunday morning I was
at church
well I come back online late Sunday
afternoon and I find many many posts and
messages from conservatives from
DeSantis supporters from people claiming
to be long time fans of mine denouncing
me for not having posted about either
subject over the weekend
so I was with my family with my wife and
kids over the weekend but that
apparently was not a good enough excuse
according to these These are I'm telling
you my mentions were just it was a
little bewildering at first because I
logged back on I saw all these people
really angry at me including people that
that I know are supposed to be on my
side and I'm thinking what did I do I
haven't even said anything
and then I realized that was the problem
uh so I just want to read a couple of
these
first one says Matt has shown himself to
be a gutless fraud if his next tweet is
not about this I'm unfollowing him
forever I'm done with these unserious
clowns
Theodore says Matt is right there with
Glenn Beck no balls but I'm sure he's
got plenty to say about how everyone
else should live and espouse his
religious book
Peter says Matt Walsh has built a
massive following commenting on
conservative politics and specifically
on transgender issues he regularly
blasts inconsequential GOP politicians
for going to the left on this but when
Trump refuses to say men can't become
women silence
Spence Rogers responding to that tweet
agreed saying great Point why because
Ben Shapiro is the authorized DeSantis
cheerleader over there Walsh isn't
allowed to talk about the primary
Knowles is the Trump Slappy Candace is
the Vivek shill m to the G says Matt
won't speak truth to power because it
affects his bottom line uh lots of
comments like that David uh said Matt
I'm so disappointed in you Trump
endorses abortion today and it's
crickets from you he cucked himself in
the trans issue and you said nothing
I've been a fan for years but now I see
that you're a turncoat Trader Sean says
Matt why aren't you speaking about these
issues about these Trump issues you've
been silent all weekend it's clear that
you aren't willing to take a risk for
the sake of Truth your account okay
so a lot where those came from
now I've already given my take on these
issues and I've already told you why I
was absent from the conversation for a
few days I realized that spending time
with your family is not an excused
absence according to the hall monitors
it is what it is
moving on from those points I just want
to say a couple other things first just
a general Point here
you look
uh
if you don't need
24-hour armed security for your family
if you've never received a letter in the
mail
making threats against you
and providing details about your home
and your movements
that that uh that they could only know
if they were watching your house
physically
if you've never had people show up
outside of your house and take pictures
of your house when your kids are playing
in the front yard
and they come running in and screaming
saying Daddy there's someone outside
if you've never experienced being doxxed
by so many people all at once that
you're trending on Twitter because of it
if you've never been hacked and
blackmailed and smeared and defamed if
you don't have a file of death threats
the size of like a novel at this point
then I just don't want to hear your
lectures about taking risks
I don't want to hear it
like I I but but I am hearing it from a
lot of people from a lot of people
well he doesn't have the courage he's
not speaking what are you doing what the
hell are you doing
many of these from Anonymous accounts
talking about political courage when
you've got nothing on the line at all
for most homeowners window replacement
isn't something they've done before and
for many it isn't something that they
want to do but rather something they
have to do if you've put off replacing
windows in your home because it's too
expensive I have great news for you you
can now get a free in-home window
consultation and free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature Services committed
to giving you the best customer
experience possible through the perfect
combination of the best people in the
industry a superior process and an
exclusive product right now Renewal by
Anderson is offering a free in-home or
virtual consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for a year text Walls to 200
300 for your free consultation to save
375 off every window and 750 off every
door these savings won't last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Walsh to
200 300 that's Walsh to 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at textplan.us texting enrolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages message data rates may apply
reply stop to opt out go to Windows
appointmentnow.com for full offer
details now I have always said what I
feel needs to be said regardless of the
consequences
and to hear lectures on political
courage from people who've put
absolutely nothing on the line
it's just it's a bit much
it just is
second this attack on me was driven
mostly by DeSantis influencers
um
whether they were paid influencers or
not I don't know
but either way they apparently decided
that it was a good political strategy to
take one of the more prominent
conservatives in Media
which is me uh who's been a de Santa
supporter for years
and cast him as the enemy
what what do you guys think this
achieves
I'm your enemy now too
me I mean I've dedicated hours of this
show over the years how was cumulative
hours
to defending DeSantis against all manner
of attacks including recently
and now I'm on your list of bad guys
what are you trying to accomplish here
what do you think this accomplishes
is it working
you know there's another disanta
supporter account with a decent
following that's been chastising me for
weeks as far as I can tell
for not being pro-desantis enough
yes you've supported him but uh but you
need to support him more we need more
really so spending hours of my show
defending him talking about him you know
how I like him why I support him that's
not enough
that's not good enough
listen if I'm not pro DeSantis enough if
I'm you know if I am your enemy now too
then who is your friend
are you just going to drive them all
away
look this is not about I don't care you
can say it it doesn't bother me it's
just such a monumentally stupid strategy
um here's the thing guys
my show
will never ever be a political ad for a
candidate it has never been and it will
never be I will never spend the majority
of my time promoting a political
candidate in fact I will spend no time
simply promoting a political candidate
I'll talk about them when they come up
in the news I'll defend them when they
are deserve defending I'll criticize
them when they deserve criticizing
um but I'm not a campaign surrogate I'll
never be one
I I've had there have been plenty of
times when uh when campaigns have
made uh you know made gestures to me as
you can imagine that they would like to
bring me into the fold to be more a part
of the team
I always turn that down
and I don't go to the dinners when I get
invited oh come to a dinner with this
candidate and we'd just like to talk to
you
and I don't begrudge candidates reaching
out with that kind of thing that's part
of the job but but I never go to the
dinners I don't do any of that
um and the reason is that that's just
not there are people who do that and
that's fine that's not who I want to be
I I want to be an independent voice I'm
not even a political pundit I don't
focus on politics I focus on culture
which is why we can go through uh major
political stories that I will almost
completely ignore in some cases because
I'm guess I'm afraid to talk about them
and the political stories are the easy
ones
it's the political stories no one's ever
threatened to kill my whole family
because of something I said about a
political story
uh but I don't I oftentimes I'll ignore
them completely just because that's not
what I focus on on this show I focus on
the culture that's what I care about
it's what I care about it's what I think
I have insight to provide on you know
many times also with these political
stories
not these particular ones we talked
about today but other stories are they
pop up and I'll look at the the
commentary that's been made on it and
I'll think yeah well most people have
covered it like I don't think I have
anything to add on this
um and so those are the ones that I'll
skip entirely uh and then other ones
will come up and I'll see a real
cultural connection like with these
Trump things you know it has to do with
trans and abortion that that really
pertains to culture and so you know I'll
do 17 minutes on that
um
but that's the way that I that's the way
that I operate that's the way that I do
the show
um
if you think that my focus should be
elsewhere if you think that I should be
a surrogate for a campaign if you think
that I should be a bigger team player or
whatever
well I don't care but all I can say is
just from a from a you know
from a strategic standpoint
like driving wedges even between
driving wedges to wedge out someone
who's on your side
could not be a dumber approach
um
and uh
there's still time to correct it there's
not a lot of time but there's still time
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there